- C'était la façon de voir
- Il ne faut jamais perdre
de vue cette détermination,
cette ténacité, cette volonté
qu'il faut pour s'astreindre
à un régime de vie
presque
- Des machines qui se sont
montrées inefficaces et d'au
qui sont devenues les ancêtres
des équipements actuels.
SUZANNE LABERGE,
professeure titulaire, UdeM
- En '66, on a découvert
que bouger... Au lieu d'user
le corps, bouger, c'était bon
poututututututututututututututu.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Mais développer sa forme
physique a un prix. Notamment,
le prix de l'effort.
- Vous n'avez pas l'impressionc,
la mise en forme?
- C'est une mode, mais
heureusement que cette mode
est arrivée, mai
gens en avaient besoin.
- Au tournant des années 80,
la recherche de la formuleuvuvur
la danse aérobique.
- Vers l'ava
FRANCE CASTEL, animatrice
- Un disque qui est une méthode
de danse aérobique. e e e e e e,
quand ils vont vouloir,
à l'heure orrrrrrrr
convenir. Puis finalement,
ils n'ont pas à débourser des
♪ ♪ ♪
- Jane Fonda devient u
ou sur cassette video,
les entraînements en sololelele.
- On pourrait faire la chosecoce
et puis avoir des blessures.
Et il manquait le social.
- Pendant des années,
les abonnements au gymnase
Surtout en début d'année, avec
les habituelles résolutions.sost
par s'essouffler.
NATHALIE LAMBERT, entraîneuse
et médaillée
- Janvier, c'est les partys
de Noël, le surplus de poids,
les pantalons un pncncncncncncns
de la nouvelle année.
Malheureusement, ça se traduit
aussi par beaucoup d'abandons
quelques mois plus tar
- L'industrie de la mise
en forme veut donc faire
en sorte que les clients
maintiennent leur motivation.
- Elle la trouve beaucoup moins
dans l'idéieieieieieieieieieille
résolution du nouvel an que
dans le désir de rester
en bonne santé.
- Avec d
qui vieillissent,
des amis qui tombent malades,
je me suis rendue compte quempm.
- Je ne pouvais plus me voire e.
♪ ♪ ♪
à l'aquaforme, les formules
se sont diversifiées
au fil du temps.
- Les gens aiment le nouveau.
Alors, il faut trouver une b b .
- 26! 27!
- L'entraînement à ciel ouvert
est devenu une tendance lourde.
- Allez-y doucem
dehors depuis un bon moment...Ae
et pdg, Cardio Plein Air
- C'est pas si épeur
et ça peut être très énergisant.
- Les modes changent,omomomomoms
de ceux qui veulent bouger.
(conversation)
En
ou encore du crossfit.
- Après, autant les activitésdee
l'étirement. Étirer les muscles
qui ont été très contractés.ecea
pandémie, il a fallu se rabattre
sur l'entraînement en ligne.
Pour n
la formule idéale est aussisosot
à la kyrielle d'obligations
que j'ai, je n
Je ne le ferai pas.
Radio-Canada, Montréa